the prayer service alongside his family
just hours before the start of derek
chauvin's murder trial
chauvin former minneapolis police
officer is accused of killing floyd in
may last year
the case is expected to center around
the question of what led to floyd's
death
if convicted siobhan could face decades
in prison
john hendren has more from minneapolis
george floyd's death reignited the u.s
civil rights movement
and set off a racial revolution in
american streets
it energized the black lives matter
movement and hardened the country's
racial divide
now the trial of the police officer
accused of floyd's murder could either
close a bitter chapter in american
history
or rekindle the arson-fueled riots of
the summer of 2020
across the united states i mean i think
it'll be similar to
what took place when this happened you
know we felt it all the way in chicago
you know people angry and
venting their frustrations which way
they know how the murder trial of fired
police officer derrick chauvin is
perhaps the most
anticipated civil rights case here in
the u.s in the 21st
century it will mark a test case of
racial justice in 2021 in the case
of a black man who died beneath the knee
of a white police officer
who held him there for eight minutes and
46 seconds
that jury will see chauvin in this
disturbing video
as floyd cries out for his life i can't
breathe
please leave my dick we don't take
anything for granted
we have to keep our eyes on the prize to
make sure
that he doesn't get away with murder had
as
so many other police officers have done
to people of color
in america not since the racially
charged trial of the white police
officers charged in the 1991 beating of
rodney king
has one legal case so captured a moment
in american racial history
[Applause]
when a largely white suburban jury found
the defendants not guilty
the streets of los angeles erupted in
violent fury
in black america police are now often
seen in the darkest light
now people are not viewing the police as
a welcome presence in the community but
rather as an
unwelcome presence as it's been referred
to over the years
an occupying force
as minneapolis anxiously boards up for
new demonstrations
many fear what could happen if chauvin
is allowed to walk free
people going to be outraged because it
again has proven that the system is not
protecting us and so i think people are
going to be
upset and they are right all right we
have 15.
this time a racially diverse jury of 12
and three alternates
nine white four black and two mixed race
will decide the fate of another white
police officer
and that could set the direction of the
american civil rights movement
for years to come john hendren al
jazeera minneapolis